what would happen if you fell into a  pool full of liquid nitrogen liquid  nitrogen has an extremely low  temperature of minus 196 degrees celsius  but if you quickly dipped your hand into  the substance it would feel frozen but  there wouldn't be any frostbite damage  this is due to the leidenfrost effect  this causes a vapor barrier to form  around your hand when you dip it quickly  enough into the liquid nitrogen but if  you touch the liquid nitrogen any longer  then you would experience severe  frostbite and not just on your skin but  the cold would work its way inside of  you freezing your fat  then muscles and blood  eventually your body would be frozen  solid and you could be easily cracked  apart so have you ever wondered